this word is polymorph polymorphs a
crystals of the same compound but where
the parts the molecules in the crystal
are arranged in a different way so
chemically they're identical but usually
not always they're salts and the way
that the positive and the negative ly
charged ions fit together in the crystal
structure is different is particularly
common with pharmaceutical compounds
because pharmaceutical compounds tend to
be quite complicated molecules so they
don't fit together very well in the
crystal they're not like the round
sodium and chloride ions in sodium
chloride so why does it matter why are
people interested in polymorphs the
problem is that different polymorphs of
the same compound often have different
solubility say in water or in acid so if
you imagine you take a pharmaceutical
compound as a pill you swallow it if
it's one polymorph it will dissolve much
more quickly in your stomach than
another one so your dose would be
different so in the pharmaceutical
industry it's very important that you
always produce the same polymorph of the
compound that you're going to sell as a
pharmaceutical product the difficulty is
that when you have something
crystallizing the crystallization
begins often with a tiny crystal that
starts as a nucleus that sets everything
else off once something decides to
crystallize in a polymorph nearly the
whole batch will go in that way and
there's several stories about factories
that are making a polymorph of a
particular pharmaceutical and the
different factory that is getting the
wrong polymorph somebody comes from that
factory to the other one and says show
me how to do it and suddenly the factory
that could do it gets the wrong
polymorph too
because the visitor has some micro
crystals or whatever in his clothes his
hair or whatever so understanding how
things crystallize is really quite an
important part of chemistry especially
when you're trying to make
pharmaceutical products I think in fact
that many if not most pharmaceutical
compounds have more than one polymorph
sometimes it's really good because you
can patent one polymorph and then when
the patterns beginning to run out you
can patent another one which somehow is
more effective so the lifetime of your
patent continues but also I read an
article once which says the number of
polymorphs on a compound really depends
on the amount of money you spend
studying it and the longer you study it
the more polymorphs you can find because
these are complicated compounds and
small changes in the crystallization
procedure can change the poly more I've
heard of things called allotropes how is
an allotrope different from a polymorph
an allotrope is a form of an element
graphite and diamond oxygen and ozone in
those cases the molecules have the atoms
bonded together in different ways in a
polymorph or in polymorphs the way that
the atoms are bonded together in the
molecule or ions are identical it's just
the way that they're stacked up that is
different and the difference in
stability may not be very great but if
one thing is twice as soluble as another
when you eat it you'll get twice as big
a dose and twice as big a dose is quite
serious